Hey Anthony.
How is project compass coming along.
>> It's going really well actually.
I just finished my front end and
I even managed to integrate
the google maps API.
Great job.
So what's your next step?
>> Well.
I was thinking I want to start adding
pictures of the places I've been to.
That's a great idea.
So if you do this one of two ways.
You can hard code images into your HTML,
or
you can create a database to
store thousands of images.
>> Well I definitely want to add as
many pictures as I possibly can.
>> Sounds like that will require some
knowledge on back end programming.
Let's check it out.
Have you ever thought about what happens
when you post data to the internet?
Like a SaaS update?
We take for granted that our
content actually shows up.
Like, how does that happen?
Process that occurs behind the scenes
requires interactions between clients.
Which is your device or
computer and servers.
A gigantic computer that processes data.
Whenever I log into my Twitter account,
my account is the client.
And I'm interacting
with Twitter servers.
When I compose a tweet and
click this button.
I'm creating a post request.
It's as if the twitter bird
carried my tweet to their servers.
My tweet is then saved
in the Twitter database.
And then sent back to my computer and
loaded on my twitter feed.
This is a post request,
I'm creating content in data and
posting it to Twitter's database.
Their servers then return
it back to my browser.
Whenever I see my Twitter feed with all
the tweets I've created in the past.
I'm creating a get request and getting
all the data from Twitter server.
When I go to my Twitter home page.
I'm creating a get requests to get all
the tweets associated with my account.
It's then sent back to my computer and
all of those sweets
are loaded on my browser.
This is a get request because I’m
getting all the data associated with my
account and
retrieving it back to my browser.
Understand that the client server model
is essential for backend programmers.
Okay, that was a lot of information.
Let's just take a moment to
review posts and get requests.